good morning believe nation today's
message is rest over to you Rick Warren
[Music]
I take Monday off Monday is my Sabbath I
don't like taking monday off because I
don't like feeling that bad on my day
off but I find that I need you to
recharge and on Mondays I am dead to the
world I do not take calls I do not read
email I do not take text messages I
sleep in I get up I play around the
house I go to lunch with my wife we
relax in the afternoon and Monday
evenings we do family night with our
families i now have grandkids that are
involved and we've kept that religiously
we've kept that faithfully over the
years and it has kept me from burning
out under enormous pressure how would
you like to pastor church where you move
the church building 79 times in the
first 13 years I did because land was so
expensive we mused 79 different
facilities of the first 13 years some
weeks I'd be in five different buildings
laguna hills high school for sunday
morning el Toro high school sunday
evening a bank building for wednesday
another one on thursday a saturday night
service at another school and or not we
said we're the church if you can figure
out where we are this week you get to
come he said we only want to church for
really intelligent people so we keep
changing the location but that was a lot
of frustration and i can tell you i have
learned to handle enormous amounts of
stress an enormous amount of tension but
i could not do it if I didn't rest my
body if I didn't take my day off if I
didn't but and don't call it your day
off call it your Sabbath salt your day
off you'll fill it with your honey-do
list all stuff it couldn't get done to
try to use it to catch up on other stuff
no it is a day of rest relaxation
relationships restoration emotionally so
you need to rest your body till
this is a really interesting one for me
because my default is to work I like to
work like I i gain calm and clarity in
my work sometimes when I rest too much
because I go on a beachy vacation I get
really antsy and frustrated I want to
work I hate just sitting down and being
on a beach for a week I can't handle
like one day but after that I want to do
something you know if Nina's away for
whatever reason my default is to work
I'm going to go back and work on
projects because it fills me up and
makes me happy so this is a harder one
for me to answer I think the best thing
that I can give you guys as my advice is
to listen to your body where some days
you may need to rest more you know if
you're feeling sick or life is
overwhelming maybe you need to rest more
and other days you're able to work more
you're able to grind it out you're able
to hustle I'm in the camps that believe
that if you're itching for a vacation if
you like can't wait to get away to get
on that vacation then something is wrong
in your life vacations can add a lot the
travel can give you lots of great ideas
can help you grow and that's a different
thing but if you're itching to get a way
to escape to just relax and wind down I
feel like there's something wrong in
your life that's my belief and instead
of once or twice a year escaping from
your life to go do something else make
your life better that's my view if you
think about how you're spending your
spare time or your free time are you
spending it in escapism are you spending
it watching big brother 18 or some
reality TV show or stupid cats fighting
each other or whatever it is like that's
escapism not super easy this what most
people do they come home and stuff my
couch and plop down and just escaped
from their life by you know being
entertained or watching the misery of
other people lives which makes them feel
better about themselves so how you spend
your time escapism or are you spending
your time trying to grow and get better
like are you spending time watching
videos are you spending time reading the
book are you spending time learning
techniques about your industry are you
spending time learning and growing if
you are unhappy with your life audit how
you're spending your extra time are you
spending your time escaping the life
that you hate or are you spending your
time growing and building so that you
can build a better life for yourself and
for me a lot of times vacation
most of the time falls into that
category of escapism like I hate my life
I hate what I'm doing I need to get away
from it and then they gotta come back
and I'll suffer some more until my next
vacation but that sucks most people live
for the evenings and weekends and
vacations as opposed to actually
enjoying it being fulfilled and the work
that you're doing every day and so the
rest one is a little bit harder for me
again because I default to work and
maybe that'll change when I'm older
maybe I'll feel like I need to rest more
but I also feel like I need to spend
time with my wife and you to spend time
with my son and you spend time with my
family and things are always kind of
fighting against each other I need to
balance my schedule to make it work
because I'm not just an entrepreneur and
only focus on business I also want to be
a successful father and a successful
husband ancestral family man it's so
part of what I do dailies look at my
goals of those categories of family main
leader and then my own personal health
to Mickey Sherman spending time on all
three of those every day so I don't know
that my advice would be to rest once a
week but i would say listen to your body
and do what's right for you the question
day today then is how important is rest
for you i'm curious how much do you rest
is it important give me some advice
share with believe nation i'm super
curious to hear what you have to say
leave it down the comments below and
we'll join in the discussion i also want
to give a quick shout out to dutch
martin Dutch thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book hear one
word it really really really really
means a lot to me and I hope you're
enjoying it thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso
[Music]